[Music]
in Oklahoma drawing oil from the earth
is nothing new it's the fifth largest
producer in the United States and the
oil and gas industry brings tens of
billions of dollars into the state
economy each year but lately there have
been some earth-shaking developments
this sounds like a sonic boom it feels
like the apartment is just gonna shift
right off the foundation it'll toss you
and then toss back where you were
earthquakes here used to be rare about
one a year but over the last six years
the number has shot through the roof in
2013 they were 109 quakes over 3.0
magnitude at the current rate 2014 could
see that triple you know when you grew
up here this isn't normal
they have coincided with the rise of
fracking to extract oil and gas from the
ground there were seven more earthquakes
today
[Music]
I've been invited to a meeting in
Stillwater at the home of Angelus spots
residents here are trying to figure out
how to counter these unsettling
developments that fall off the wall
we've been here when every picture on
this wall shook and went sideways
you're just bombarded with noise sound
dust dirt I personally feel it's very
dangerous and unfortunately it's going
to be years before the rest of the whole
country figures that out so far we
haven't had any cracks in the ceiling
but I can feel the difference in the
floor I wish people understood how much
energy is consumed to bring all that
energy up out of the ground with all the
risk how confident are you that you can
unsettle this Leviathan because it these
are the jobs right this is the economy
in Oklahoma is that your biggest
challenge here I think so I think it is
our governor's top three contributors
they're energy companies
hydraulic fracturing or fracking is the
process by which water chemicals and
sand are injected into rock to dislodge
pockets of oil and gas that wastewater
then has to be disposed of either by
dumping it into evaporation pits or by
rejecting it into the ground it's this
reinjection process that a study
conducted by the US Geological Survey
and several American universities has
linked to the earthquakes the earthquake
increase is unprecedented in Oklahoma
Bob Rebecca's is a research hydrologist
with the USGS and co-authored that study
injection has occurred in Oklahoma for
many decades it's what may be relevant
is that injection has doubled in the
same time frame in the state and so
injection rates have been increasing as
he's unconventional oil and gas
technologies have been increasing across
the state the boom in fracking is
causing friction between the industry
and landowners I'm about to go see Earl
Hadley he's been an environmental
activist for decades and is a big
opponent of fracking and wastewater
injection that looks like a wastewater
injection mmm well right mmm that's
being blamed for the earthquakes and how
many earthquakes have we had in this
area in recent times poke hard
hundreds Earl has been hearing from oil
companies who want to explore for oil on
his land in January I got a letter from
a contractor on behalf of Devon they had
a contract with the letter they want to
come onto my property and do a seismic
survey explore for oil and I just threw
it away
if they find oil the companies may not
have to ask for permission to extract it
in Oklahoma mineral ownership is
separate from land ownership which has
tipped the balance in favor of the big
oil and gas companies so you're saying
they can do what they want really how do
you fight such a big machine in Oklahoma
that's a difficult thing you have to be
brave
you have to be willing to take whatever
they throw at you for more than a month
I'd been requesting interviews with the
top oil and gas companies so now I'm
gonna try to show up on the front door
and see if they'll talk to me
hi Gordon we're doing a piece on the
wastewater injection in Oklahoma would
really appreciate if you could find the
time thanks a lot no one answered
but the Oklahoma City police arrived
soon afterward who was you supposed to
meet with well that sent multiple
requests to Gordon Pennoyer
they laugh back at her
we got a similar response from Devin the
fifth largest natural gas company in the
country so we were wondering if we could
get a line from Devin like anything on
camera so it was just a Devon Energy
Center the biggest building in town I
went to enchance my luck they threw us
out when we started researching this
story this man got in touch he drives
the trucks that carry millions of
gallons of used water from the fracking
sites to weight is disposed of
unlike the oil companies he wanted to
talk but asked us to hide his identity
what am I seeing over here this is a
reservoir where they dump their frack
trucks at farmers and landowners can
just dig a hole and charge people to
unload their frack trucks here the dirty
water that they've used well I thought
the dirty one that goes gets pumped
underground in the injection wells they
do but this is another way of disposing
of frack water you just come out here
dig a hole charge people to back in and
load he's worried about more than the
earthquakes and fears that reckless
dumping of chemical laced wastewater
into these pits will contaminate the
groundwater
there's not even turf out here this is
just ground to water the state's making
a lot of money out of this you think
they're gonna care or do anything about
it I don't think so I think that it's
good for Walmart it's good for the gas
stations it's good for everybody to have
this kind of
money coming around and I don't think
anybody's gonna say anything until the
groundwater is gone and you have to go
somewhere else to get water in Norman
Oklahoma a town-hall meeting has been
organized to discuss the local impact of
fracking with support from the Sierra
Club a national environmental group
we've done our best to make sure that
everyone can not only hear but do have
also the opportunity to at least submit
their questions both supporters and
opponents of fracking showed up from
environmental activists to hardline
conservatives the room filled up early
leaving many frustrated outside I worked
for living like a lot of people don't I
work in the woman gas industry I've been
doing it for over 45 years
okay it has to do with my wife with her
man
they have no idea what's frakkin you
know to keep tempers from boiling over
the audience was asked to submit their
questions in writing now all this talk
about potentially banning fracking is
this something that you see is possible
here in Norman could could Norman do
this is it considering it first of all
is I'm going to show you there's a state
statute that specifically contemplates
that charter cities at least have the
ability to both regulate and prohibit
the industry thank you general public in
specific parcels public they over react
to things they don't understand and they
and then and it's not an overreaction if
your ground shaking underneath you know
I mean limit what we're talking about
fracking no pennies of wastewater
injection part of the big picture
outside the forum I finally got to speak
with oil industry representatives you
guys don't believe the study has any
legs to stand on study believes that it
could be linked study does not say that
causality then correspondents are the
same thing there are corresponding
things that have happened but surely we
don't know have you got to go okay let's
look at this well there are other
corresponding things such as the massive
major earthquakes occurring over the
world at the same time that are directly
relate to what's happening in Oklahoma
so where is the anti-fracking hysteria
coming from and they're not based on
science it's true that scientists
haven't so far established that the
injection of wastewater produced by
fracking is causing the exponential rise
in earthquakes in Oklahoma
but earthquakes are a problem the future
of the freshwater supply is a concern
that there's a correlation between
fracking and both is proven yet so
polarized other positions here and so
massive is the oil and gas industry that
even if science does establish a causal
link I'm not sure this battle will stop
at all they're gonna make as much money
as what they can all I can make it
without being regulated
[Music]
you